[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVA: Welcome everybody at Talks
at Google in the Cambridge
office.
My name is Eva [? Atur ?] and
I'm a Site Program Manager
for the Munich site,
woo, all of those
that will be
looking and watching
that video later on from Munich.
So I have the great
pleasure to welcome today
at Talks at Google Professor
Jan Rivkin from the Harvard
Business School.
Since 2011, he co-chairs the
project on US competitiveness
with professor Michael Porter.
And he will talk
about that today.
And this project
unleashed a number
of discussions around
the business leaders
on how to make US health
and economic growth grow.
And when I was talking
about the Talks at Google
with Professor Rivkin,
we laughed a little bit
around the cases that
we discussed at Harvard
around 2000, 2002
about Yahoo and Lycos,
where some of the students were
arguing heavily and intensely
that search and internet
portals would become commodity,
and there is no money
to be made there.
Well, this turned out to be
a lot of different story.
So without further
ado, I just want
to welcome Professor
Jan Rivkin on stage.
JAN RIVKIN: Wonderful.
EVA: Thank you.
JAN RIVKIN: Thank you, Eva.
Thank you for the
kind introduction.
You mentioned the old Yahoo
and Lycos cases that I wrote.
The story is actually
even worse than that.
It turns out I also
wrote a case years
ago on Microsoft's efforts
in search, what became Bing.
So you may think that I
am some kind of, you know,
bad luck charm, bringing harm
to every search company I visit.
You might want to
escort me to the door
before I cause any
damage to Google.
I do want to reassure
you I have written
some cases on some successful
organizations as well.
So it actually is remarkable.
20 years ago you could write
a case in the online space
and never mention Google.
And yet here we are.
And the company is one most
influential organizations
on the planet.
So it's a pleasure
and a privilege
to share with you
some of the work we've
done on US competitiveness.
This work has been done as
a project team, about two
dozen faculty involved to date.
I will, of course,
speak to myself.
But I just want to acknowledge
the debt I owe to my colleagues
in that regard,
truly joint work.
Now, when I got
the nice invitation
to come speak with you today,
I of course did my homework.
I looked at some prior talks.
I noticed some of the talks were
deeply analytical, just what I
would expect from Google.
Some of them included
a call to action.
And I'm going to try
to do both today.
The analytical part
will delve into the lack
of shared prosperity we see
in the American economy.
Once upon a time in America,
the prosperity we generated
was shared pretty broadly
so that rich Americans,
middle class Americans,
poor Americans
we either thrived together,
or we struggle together.
And since all boats either
rose or fell with the tide,
the challenge was
fairly straightforward.
How do we keep the
tide coming in?
All right?
But that is not what we see
in the American economy today.
Instead, what I think we see is
an economy doing half its job
where big companies and the
people who work for them
and invest in them
are doing pretty well.
But working class,
middle class Americans
are struggling, as are
many small businesses.
And I've become convinced
this is the number one
economic, social, and
increasingly political problem
in our country.
That many of the things that
might concern many of us--
the rise of populism, even the
financial crisis of the last
decade--
are as much causes of
that lack of shared
prosperity as independent
events in and of themselves.
And I want to share with you
some fairly sobering symptoms,
as well as offer a
diagnosis before I
move to the prescription.
Now, with the prescription,
that brings me
to the call to action.
And the call to
action is embodied
in the title of the
talk, "Will We Restore
Shared Prosperity in America?"
I chose the title
very deliberately.
It's not can we.
Sometimes, you read
stuff out there
that makes it feel like
the economic outcomes will
be dictated by inexorable
forces of global change
or technological change.
I actually believe those forces
are extraordinarily important.
But I also believe
what we have here
is essentially a social choice.
We get to decide.
And I want to take
the talk personally.
I believe that
people with Google,
individually and
collectively, can actually
help to shape and make
that social decision.
It will require, I believe, an
approach, an approach that's
not discussed as
much as it should be,
an approach that I'll try
to highlight and illustrate
when I move to the
prescription, an approach
that I actually see
already implicit in some
of the social and philanthropic
efforts of the company,
but an approach that I think
is actually made more powerful
if we make it explicit.
So that's where I'm heading.
I want to start with the
symptoms and just some facts
about prosperity
in America today.
I'm going to start
with the good news.
I will warn you the good news
is not going to last very long.
And this could be a bit
of a roller coaster ride.
I promise everyone you
cannot leave without an equal
and opposite offsetting
dose of optimism by the end.
OK?
But bear with me through
some of the sobering stuff.
The good news first, though.
Total prosperity in
America-- turns out
we're generating lots of
prosperity in the country.
One indicator of this is
gross domestic product.
Here we've got
real GDP in America
over time indexed back to 1995
shown versus Europe and Japan.
And the good news is that,
in fact, the American economy
powered into and powered out
of the great recession stronger
than the other advanced
economies of the world.
Now, it turns out the
growth rates here,
they are lower than
we saw in the years
immediately after World War II.
They're relatively low.
But the total pie, the total
pie is growing pretty well.
Now, part of that pie shows
up as corporate profit.
This looks like good news too.
So it turns up, when you only
looks at corporate profit,
either as a portion of GDP,
in red and on the right,
or in total real dollars,
in blue and on the left.
Corporate profits are close
to all-time record highs.
OK, so the corporate part of
the pie is just doing fine.
Now, I want to turn
what's happening outside
of the corporate sector.
And I'm going to start by
focusing on income, right,
a key indicator of prosperity,
and income distribution
and actually look at income
from like four different angles.
So you can see
different aspects of it.
You can get it totaled up.
And I'll also look at
two things that drive
it-- job growth and startups.
With income, I want to
start with, I think,
a tremendously interesting
and sobering analysis
that some colleagues at
Berkeley and in France
did very recently.
They took the
income distribution.
They looked at individuals
in each percentile.
OK?
And they asked, over the
first half and the second half
of the post-war
period, how did income
grow for individuals in each
percentile of the income
distribution.
So this is the first half
of the post-war period,
1946 through 1980.
And this is different points
in the income distribution.
And first of all, the
good news is the line
as a whole is pretty high.
That's terrific.
And in fact, the
poorest Americans
saw the greatest percentage
gains in real income.
And the richest Americans saw
modest gains, but still gains,
but lower gains.
Now, we move forward
to the second half
of the post-war period,
1980 through 2014.
And the line rotates
dramatically.
OK?
All right, I mean your gasp is
exactly my reaction as well.
So what do we see here?
We see the poorest Americans,
basically, barely keeping up.
We see the very, very,
very wealthiest Americans
seeing unprecedented
gains in income over time.
All right?
So there you get the
whole distribution.
Let's now zero in on
one particular point.
Let's zero in on the median and
look at the median over time.
Because if we had
a world-- if we
had a country of
shared prosperity,
we'd expect to see median
household income in real terms,
in inflation-adjusted
terms, going up over time.
All right?
We might see ups and
downs around recessions,
but, generally, an upward trend.
If you look back far enough
at median household income,
that's actually what we saw,
all right, from 1975 here
to around the year 2000.
Yeah, there's ups and
downs around the recession,
but basically an upward trend.
But then things peak in 1999.
We see stagnation, decline.
We do see some gains
in recent years.
And in fact, the data that
were released two weeks ago
showed that real
median household
income exceeded the 1999
peak for the first time.
People celebrated, and
we should celebrate.
We should also keep in mind
exactly what we're celebrating.
We're celebrating
that we are back
to where we were 17 years ago.
OK?
This is not just
true at the median.
It's true all the way down to
the very bottom of the income
distribution.
And it goes up to around
the 95th or above percentile
that since 1999 we've seen
essentially stagnation, decline
and then recovery.
So that's deeply sobering.
Another thing is just looking
at how it spread geographically.
So let's now zero in on 15
years from 1999 to 2014.
and look at the change in
real median household income.
But now, let's do it
by county in the US.
And what you see
here is declines
in real median household income
in the reds, the oranges,
the shades of
yellow and increases
in the blues and the whites.
And you can see deep declines
in the Midwest, deep declines
in the South, the Northeast and
the Rockies not quite as bad.
You actually see gains in
a big chunk of the country
where there are very few people.
And you can almost
make-- you can actually
make out the oil shale fields
in North Dakota and west Texas.
Right?
If you squint very hard,
you squint very hard,
you can see some highly
populous but prosperous pockets
on the coasts.
So you can see Boston.
You can see the Bay Area.
You can see Washington DC.
You can see LA.
But both in terms of the gains
across the income distribution
and also gains across the
country, really uneven outcomes
on median household income.
All right?
The last angle on income
I want to give you
is something that
colleagues in the Econ
Department at Harvard and
Stanford have shown recently.
They did a very clever analysis.
They basically ask first
what is the American dream.
And they realized that at
least one key component of it
is my kids are
better off than I am,
and I'm better off
than my parents.
So they took tax records,
looked at income,
and linked together
parents and kids.
And they can look at people
in different birth cohorts
and ask, for instance,
for someone born in 1940,
when they were age 30 in
1970, are they better off
than their parents were
when their parents were
30 years old.
It turns out for someone born in
1940, the answer was about 90%
of them were better off than
their parents at age 30.
OK?
But you can see, you know,
the decline in this figure.
All the way to, you
know, those born in 1984,
who turned 30 in 2014 when the
data set ends, it turns out
only half of them are better
off than their parents
were at age 30.
So it's gone from being a
kind of 90%, almost a sure
bet, to being a coin toss.
Now, I promised sobering data.
Right?
So are we sobered so far?
I'm afraid you are.
I want to look at two
underlying drivers of income
and prosperity and
shared prosperity.
One is job creation.
Another is startups.
So in job creation, I
want to take a quick look
at the great American
job machine, right,
which clearly is a driver
of shared prosperity.
And here's one
way to look at it.
It's the rolling 10-year
compounded annual growth
rate and the number
of private-sector jobs
in the country.
So the number for 1985 was 2.7%.
That means in the
decade before 1985,
the economy produced new jobs at
an average annual clip of 2.7%.
All right?
And you can see that,
for a long period,
the great American
job machine could
be counted upon in
any given decade
to produce new jobs at
about 2% clip per year.
There'd be ups and
downs within the decade.
But give me a decade.
I can give you 2% annual growth.
And then somewhere around
2000, something happens.
The job machine
starts to sputter.
All right?
And we drop to historically
low rates of job growth,
which for working and
middle class Americans
is a deeply distressing outcome.
I also want to turn,
particularly for this crowd,
I thought turn to startups.
All right?
I think most of us have
the impression, certainly
on campus where I live,
it seems like it's
the golden age of startups.
Like if you're at HBS as
an MBA, and you're not
involved in two startups,
people will wonder what
you're doing with your time.
Right?
And I think-- when you think
about it, barriers to entry
have fallen.
We can now outsource production.
We can market via Google.
We can deliver via UPS.
Seems like barriers to
entry have come down.
It turns out that impression
is true inside a particularly
small bubble.
And if you actually
look at the startups
as a portion of all US firms,
it's been in steady decline
since the late 1970s.
On Tuesday of this
week, they actually
released the 2015 data.
It's up a tiny little
bit, a tenth of a point.
Now, just to remind
you, again, it's
not that we're not
producing prosperity.
It's that we're not
producing shared prosperity.
And just to reinforce
that, here's
a chart where we
look at two things--
blue and on the left,
the average income
in real dollars among
those in the bottom 99%
of the population over a
very long period of time,
going back basically to
when we started doing income
taxes in America in 1913, and
then, in red and on the right,
what happens for
those in the top 1%.
So you can see very clearly,
from about the end of World War
II through the mid-1970s,
this is essentially
the golden age of the
American middle class
and then, from the mid-1980s
until very recently,
maybe even today, the
golden age of the 1%.
So we've got a
situation where we
see a true, deep lack of shared
prosperity in the country.
And I'm sorry to show you the
baby from different angles.
But the baby is ugly from
each direction, I'm afraid.
What's going on?
We need to move from just the
symptoms to the diagnosis.
I want to offer a basic
narrative that I think captures
a lot of what's going on.
It's not going to
capture everything.
All right?
But I think it'll
capture the basics.
It starts with an idea.
And it's an idea that my
colleagues Gary Pisano
and Willy Shih have really made
central in my own thinking.
It's the idea of the commons--
that there are certain shared
resources that every citizen,
every community, every
company relies upon
in order to be productive
and prosperous.
Every community needs
a educated populace,
needs a skilled workforce,
needs a strong infrastructure,
some basic R&D. All Right
And the truly amazing thing
about the United States,
historically, is that
locally invested companies
and a functioning government at
the federal and the local level
managed to invest
deeply and build
the most productive commons
the world had ever seen.
In fact, we not only built
a productive commons.
We were innovators in this.
From the
transcontinental railroad
to the interstate highway system
from universal public education
in the 1840s to the GI
Bill after World War II,
we innovated it and
built the commons.
Now, I do want to
be very, very clear.
This was not good for everyone.
Like the good old days was not--
they just weren't so good across
big portions of population.
The interstate
highway system cut
through the heart of many
African-American neighborhoods.
The GI Bill was not shared
equally across the population,
either racially--
very few women benefited from
the GI Bill, for instance.
But for a big chunk
of the population,
we built a strong commons.
Then what happens?
We hit around 1980,
and we see changes
in geopolitics,
changes in technology,
changes in governance.
Suddenly, we create
automation and globalization.
It becomes possible
to do business
from anywhere to anywhere.
And we start to get
new technologies
for automating jobs.
All right?
And this had tremendous
benefits for the US economy.
Let's be very clear.
This was beneficial.
But it also tended to weaken the
connections between companies
and their communities,
the connections that
had made companies eager to
invest in the local commons.
If I am born in a
small city, and I
know that I'm going to be
starting my business, growing
my business, and, you
know, living in a community
where I've got to rely upon the
local public education system,
I've got really strong
incentive to make sure
that school system
operates well.
So but we've got now a situation
where there's globalization
and additional automation.
So maybe I can replace
individuals with machinery.
So the incentives to invest in
the commons among businesses
deteriorates.
This, of course,
puts intense pressure
on the middle class
in our society.
Right?
Middle class, working
class, finds itself
in intense competition for
jobs with hundreds of millions
of ambitious, skilled
workers around the world,
and also, implicitly, competing
for jobs against technology
that's improving at the
rate of Moore's law.
On the other hand, on the other
end of the skills distribution,
if you happen to have unique
skills that you can market
globally and can be
leveraged by technology,
this is a great moment.
Right?
So income inequality starts
to rise at this point.
Then the next question becomes
how did we, as a society,
respond to pressure
in the middle class.
We could have doubled
down, I think,
on making the middle
class so, you know,
so educated, so
skilled, so supported
by strong infrastructure and
other parts of the commons
that it can compete with anyone,
anywhere around the world.
All right?
Instead, what we honestly did--
and let me be clear.
I don't want to pin this on
one political party or another.
I think there's enough blame
here to go around, actually.
I think what we
did, as a society,
is we made a series of
unsustainable promises
to maintain the illusion
of shared prosperity,
even as things started
to deteriorate.
They're promises like
please, middle class,
don't worry about your
stagnant household income.
We will extend
additional credit to you.
Please go out and
buy more stuff.
Particularly, buy houses.
Right?
So after the dot.com
bubble bursts,
we keep interest rates low,
encouraging house buying.
And we build a
bubble, which we come
to live with during
the financial crisis.
Promises like the
government will directly
cover your health care
costs during your retirement
and promises like we'll do
all of this while lowering
tax rates in every tax bracket.
Right?
You take those promises.
You couple them with two
wars and a nasty recession.
And you wind up
with a government,
which is both financially
hobbled and politically
divided.
And where do the cuts come?
Basically, they come in
investments in the comments.
Right?
So you wind up with footloose
firms and a hobbled government.
And who's making the
investments in infrastructure,
to individuals and
innovation, and so forth?
Unfortunately, not
enough anywhere.
Right?
Now, one particular
look at this issue
comes from surveys we've done,
as part of the Competitiveness
Project, of our alumni.
So we're fortunate to
have tens of thousands
of alums around the
world who will generously
share their perspective
from the front lines
of global capitalism.
Among the things that
we've asked them,
we've asked them to look
at a bunch of elements
of the business
environment in America,
which prior research
has shown to be
drivers of competitiveness and
drivers of shared prosperity.
And for about each of these, we
asked them two basic questions.
The first question was
how's the US doing compared
to other advanced economies.
That will become
my horizontal axis.
And then we've asked what's
America's trajectory.
Are we getting better
or staying the same,
getting worse in
each one of these?
And that will be
the vertical axis.
Now, the great news
about the US is,
in fact, we've got some
great strengths that
are getting even better.
We've got a great
context for innovation.
We've got vibrant
capital markets.
We've got high-quality
firm management.
We've got great
research universities.
The problem is those
strengths are weighed down
by other strengths that
are getting worse--
our pools of skilled labor,
our macroeconomic policy,
for instance, our
regulatory system--
and by weaknesses
that are getting worse
in the eyes of our alums--
a convoluted tax code, a
paralyzed political system
at the national level, a
costly healthcare system,
a very patchy, uneven K
through 12 education system,
and logistics and infrastructure
with significant weaknesses.
Now, if you stare
at that chart, you
can essentially see, with
a little bit of squinting,
the underlying drivers
of the lack of shared
prosperity in the country.
Because think about it.
If you're a large corporation,
running a large corporation,
what do you need to do well?
You need access to innovation.
You need great
research universities.
You need great capital markets.
You need great firm management.
And frankly, if you don't
like the national environment,
you are one--
you're like one tax
code, one inversion,
away from getting away from the
convoluted tax code in the US.
You can source talent
from around the world.
So the K through 12 system is
not a barrier to your progress.
On the other hand, if you
are a working or middle
class American, you bring
to work your education,
your workforce skills.
And you can't escape
the consequences
of the national
political system.
You can't escape the
consequences of the healthcare
system.
So essentially, what
you've got is large firms
that can tap the
strengths of the economy
and can escape the weaknesses
and many, many citizens
who are reliant
upon the weaknesses
and can't escape
from those weaknesses
as well and very rarely
actually tap into the strengths.
So that diagnosis,
it acknowledges
things that are kind
of inexorable forces
like globalization and
technological change.
But it also says look.
We have here a
self-inflicted wound.
The self-inflicted wound is
systematic under-investment
in the commons on which
many, many Americans depend.
And the question becomes how
might we fix that problem.
And this leads to
the prescription
and, ultimately, to
the call to action.
On the prescription
side, let me lay out,
with a little bit caricature,
what I hear as the major ways
people talk about restoring
shared prosperity in America.
There are folks who
will basically--
and I will confess I think
there are largely politicians--
who will essentially say
my plan is to reverse time.
OK?
I'm going to stop globalization
by putting up barriers.
And we're going
to tax the robots.
And we're going to basically--
don't worry about automation.
You could probably
hold back the tide
a little bit there
for a little bit.
But I think if America
resists the future,
while the rest of the
world embraces it,
the country will not wind up in
a good place in the long run.
Second you hear lots
of talks about efforts
to redistribute
income, to redistribute
the gains very directly
and more progressive tax
code, higher minimum wages, at
the extreme, universal basic
income.
Right?
Once you start
talking about these,
one's politics quickly
come out to the front.
I'll confess mine.
I think we need to talk about
these things very seriously.
All right, I also live
enough in the real world
to realize that, legislatively,
these things are not
likely to happen.
All right, so we have
to find other things.
If we're serious about
restoring shared prosperity,
we, individually, in our
own wish, may work on those,
but we have to work on
other things as well.
The third category
I'd say is efforts
to boost overall growth rates.
There are people who say,
look, what we really need--
let's just boost overall growth.
And then the boats will
rise with the tide.
If you really believe that
prosperity in aggregate
will automatically bring shared
prosperity in the country,
you've kind of not
been paying attention
for the past couple of decades.
And then, finally, and where
I find the greatest hope is
efforts to restore the commons.
And these are region
by region efforts.
They are local efforts.
And they are cross-sector.
They involve business.
Almost all the time, they
never involve only business.
And they are highly innovative.
And I'll just lay
out a few examples
to give you a taste,
a concrete taste,
of what I'm talking about.
So one of my favorite
ones involves
a company called Southwire.
South is a multibillion dollar
maker of cable and wire.
There's a one in five chance
their product is actually
in your wall at home or my
wall, but we don't know it.
Right?
The Chief Executive of Southwire
realized he had a problem.
He committed to hire only
high school Graduates
And in rural Carroll
County, Georgia,
where the company
is based, there just
weren't enough people
graduating from high school.
So he and his team partnered
with the local school district
and said to the
school district bring
us the most at-risk
students in your system,
OK, like the people
you are confident
are going to drop out.
And we will build a dedicated
factory, staffed entirely
by at-risk high school
students, managed by teachers
and by Southwire managers.
And the students, if they
go to school in the morning,
can then work a
four-hour shift for pay
at Southwire in this dedicated
factory in the afternoon.
So it turns out this
leads the graduation
rate for these at-risk students
to go flying through the roof.
It's above the system average.
The graduation rate
among at-risk students
who are in the county, but
not in this program, even that
goes up because of peer effects.
The managers at
Southwire who are
doing this adore doing this.
It gives extra
meaning to their work.
The school system is delighted.
And then here's
the kicker for me.
It turns out that a
well-managed, well-trained high
school student is about 35%
more productive than a grownup.
So the factory, the
factory that they
hoped might one day
break even, actually
starts to print money in month
three, money they then reinvest
in growing the program.
So that's just one example.
You can see cross-sector.
It involves business.
It involves educators.
It involves the local
government to some extent.
And it makes a difference
to building the commons
in that community.
Siemens, you know,
global multinational,
they're energy
equipment business
is based in Charlotte,
North Carolina.
They realized they
had a problem.
Their problem was
they could not find
enough advanced manufacturing
workers in the local workforce.
So you know, Siemens
can go anywhere.
But instead, they say
they're going to double down
in North Carolina.
They partner with Central
Piedmont Community College,
essentially, to train
the workers they
would love to hire.
All right, so this means
a deep partnership.
It means helping to reform the
curriculum in the community
college.
It means donating equipment.
It means donating software.
It means a change for the
community college too.
They've got to take
their instructors,
change the curriculum, send
them to Germany to understand
the apprenticeship in
Germany, the apprenticeship
system in Germany.
But the consequence is a
highly skilled workforce,
which is useful not only
for Siemens, but also
for other advanced
manufacturers in the community.
So once again, multi-sector,
local in its character
and, also, in this case
and in other cases,
involving young leaders.
I may come back to the Itasca
Project if we have time.
But the Young American
Leaders Project,
this is my personal favorite.
I've been deeply
involved in this one.
One thing we realized at
Harvard Business School, as we
collected scores upon
scores of examples
like this of local cross-sector
collaborations that
were rebuilding
the commons, making
a difference in the individual
communities, what we realized
is the ideas weren't spreading.
They were bottled up
in local communities.
We'd go to Nashville
and talk about what
we'd seen in Chattanooga,
three hours down the road,
and they hadn't heard of it.
So we launched the
following effort.
We chose nine cities and went to
senior leaders in those cities
and said look, identify
for us 10 young leaders
who you believe will
help lead the city
in the next generation.
And they should come from
business and government
and nonprofits and
educational institutions
and faith-based organizations,
from anywhere in the community.
All right, just
bring them to us.
And nine cities times
10 people, now, we've
got a classroom full.
All right, so we
bring them to campus
for essentially a
week-long boot camp
in cross-sector collaboration
for shared prosperity.
And I want to tell
you, if you want
to feel optimistic
about America,
turn off CNN, turn off Fox
News, put down the newspaper,
and spend a week in a classroom
with these young leaders.
It's They're truly inspiring,
truly extraordinary the things
they're doing.
So this brings me, in
fact, to my kind of call
to action for you.
Yeah, I've had the privilege
of having a lot of my students
either come from Google
or go to Google afterwards
or to other highly
influential organizations.
And I think one of the great
pleasures of working at a place
like Google is you get
to ask yourself every day
am I changing the world.
All right, but I want to
add a question to your list.
And the question is am
I changing my community.
All right, am I changing my
community in collaboration
with cross-sector leaders in
other parts of the community?
Am I working well
to build the commons
in my community with
leaders in local government,
leaders in nonprofits, leaders
in educational institutions?
Because I think, ultimately,
that kind of collaboration,
involving businessmen,
involving many others,
and working at the local
level to build the commons
and bring back
shared prosperity,
that is the best bet
we have right now.
So thanks for hearing
me out on this.
Let me open it up for questions,
thoughts, reflections.
I'd love to hear what
you think about this.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so your call
to action is very well taken.
You know, we certainly
all have a responsibility.
But in studies of
income inequality
that I've read,
another huge factor,
there's a strong correlation
between the overweening
strength of the
financial sector--
that excess and anomalous
returns to the financial world,
lower regulations, seems to
be very strongly correlated
with income inequality,
hedge fund billionaires
being taxed less at carried
interest rates, and so on.
And a lot of those
people are HBS grads.
So to what extent can I
turn the tables and ask
is there institutional
responsibility on that side?
JAN RIVKIN: It's a
very fair question.
The easy answer to is there
institutional responsibility
is yes.
All right?
And just to drive
home your point,
when you look back
at this chart,
you ask who are these
individuals up here,
and they are disproportionately
in the financial sector.
All right, so boy,
it's a great question.
I am certain the question
is better than the answer
I will give it.
So yes, there is an
institutional responsibility,
I think, to encourage
our students
to think broadly about
how they create value
before capturing value.
All right, and in
fact, it goes back
to the very early history
of Harvard Business School.
The first dean, his
statement to the mission
was to educate people to make
a decent profit decently.
Right?
I think that there
are, in fact, steps
that we and our peer
institutions have made.
You know, we have
a first-year course
that looks entirely
at leadership
and corporate
accountability that
asks what are you
responsibilities to all
your stakeholders.
We've got colleagues, Rebecca
Henderson and George Serafeim,
teaching a course called
Reimagining Capitalism, which
asks the question can capitalism
be a source of solutions
to the world's
thorniest problems.
They focus on climate change,
inequality, and corruption.
You know, I think we often
think of businesses being
a cause of those problems.
And they ask can
business, in fact,
be a solution to those problems.
And it's a having
oversubscribed course.
So
And I've got literally
dozens of colleagues
who look at the future
of market capitalism
and conclude that we've got
to have changes in that.
Lynn Paine and Joe Bower, in
a recent "Harvard Business
Review" article, basically
came to a creek very similar
to yours, asking if the focus
on devotion to shareholder value
alone leads to outcomes in our
society that are unsustainable.
So I think we've got many
folks who are looking
into how we address these.
I personally would like to
see changes in how we treat,
for instance, carried interest.
I also am fairly sober about
the legislative changes there
that would be required
to pull that off.
Perhaps, you're more optimistic
than I am about that route.
I don't know.
Would you say you are?
Or--
AUDIENCE: It's tough to say.
Right?
I mean the current plan
doesn't seem conducive.
But, you know, we have had
more equitable situations
in the past.
And so maybe the silver
lining in today's situation,
if things are perceived
to be broken enough,
that will create
momentum for change.
JAN RIVKIN: Yeah,
and the last time
we saw inequality at this level
was right before the Great
Depression.
All right, and that
induced, you know,
in a horribly traumatic
way for our society,
many of the changes
that I suspect you
would be very supportive of.
My hope is that do it
this time without a Great
Depression and a World War.
But I'm also--
I feel very sober about that.
And I would look at how
financial regulation,
regulations affect
the financial sector,
has gone since the
financial crisis.
And I worry that we've
made very little progress.
It is why I place my personal
bets at the local level
where I see, particularly
local politicians,
it turns out, you know,
that there's just a greater
degree of accountability
because their trash has
got to be picked up, and the
snow has got to be cleared.
And otherwise, there
are consequences
that re very real
and almost immediate.
I'd love to see changes
at different levels.
But I try to work where I
think I can make a difference.
And I encourage others
to work at both levels.
Please, other
thoughts, reflections.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
This is amazing.
I probably have 1,000 questions.
But the one that comes
to my mind-- and I'm
just interested in
your perspective--
is, when we talk about
barriers to reaching the shared
prosperity, one of the
places that at least I place
a lot of blame is the media.
And I think they don't have a--
they aren't driven by this.
Right?
Like a shared prosperity
doesn't really rise their tide.
It's almost like
the divisiveness
and getting people--
bad news is what sells.
Like how do we
overcome as a society
when we have an us-versus-them,
a CNN versus Fox News?
And people are driven
down by wherever they are.
And it's sort of like--
how do we-- if you have
an entire industry that's
not built around
shared prosperity,
how do we ever achieve it?
JAN RIVKIN: Wow, OK, so
that's a huge, deep question.
And I'm going to say
the very same thing.
My answer probably won't be so--
the first thing I'd reflect on
is there's reason the
media is plural, actually.
All right, I think there are
many, many media out there.
And I see some that
do cover the good news
and really are
focused on this, and I
see some that seem
to benefit by feeding
the divisions in our society.
And actually, I
worry, if anything,
the media is being beaten down.
And it plays an important
role in our body politic.
And it's being de-legitimized.
So while I will criticize
parts of the media,
I also want to come to
their defense at this time.
You know, I do think, well, at
least one piece of good news
here is that these innovative,
cross-sector collaborations
actually do attract a fair
amount of media attention.
And they, you know, just
choosing some local examples,
so Jon Feinman started
InnerCity Weightlifting.
I don't know if
Google is actually--
Microsoft here in Kendall
Square is involved.
This is an effort to get
businesses and others engaged
in keeping individuals with
records of incarceration
employed, positive, and not
going back to jail, basically.
It turns out rates of recidivism
are just insanely high
and partly because there's
just no opportunity.
Because you come out of jail,
and the first thing someone
asks you is have you
been incarcerated.
Yes, you have.
Thank you for applying.
But no thank you for the job.
Right
So InnerCity
Weightlifting is an effort
to train the
individuals coming out
of jail to be personal
trainers and, particularly,
personal trainers for, in
part, people of real means
who can then create
opportunities
for these individuals.
ICW, InnerCity Weightlifting,
has got a lot of publicity
in the local area.
It could use even more.
But it's gotten a lot.
So I do think there's
a possibility.
Can I turn-- so I've
got to tell you.
I'm a case method instructor.
So my natural inclination is
to turn the question back.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Like I said,
I couldn't agree more
about the role that the
media is going to have
to play to get us out of this.
I just think there are,
like I said I think,
if you look at the worst of
it, they're driven by division.
Because the more
division, the more people
are going to tune into their
news and the breaking news
and everything else.
I think it's also somewhat
scary that what drives
people, when you look at it
from the emotional standpoint,
is risk and fear.
And so it's like, when you
look at individual gains,
be it from media
companies or individuals
in the political world,
it's like if you're
tapping into that
emotion, it's what's
going to get you to continue
to tune in, continue to click.
So I just I don't know.
I'm fearful of how do
we break that cycle.
JAN RIVKIN: So for some reason,
division sells for the media.
Right?
They're not choosing
to publicize division
because they just like
division, I don't think.
I think that actually there
are strong incentives.
So how could we recreate a
media where unity sold instead?
I mean I'm going to
make it very concrete.
Can you imagine doing
things within Google
so that the other
kinds of stories,
actually, were highly
attractive to individuals?
Or maybe it's deep
in the customer base
where we just like division,
and we love bad news.
But I don't know
that's the case.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no, I
think there is a lot.
And I think these companies are
doing a ton, including Google.
I just I fear that other
sides of the equation
will just talk
about these bubbles
that these companies live in.
Or and I mean, obviously,
Google was just in the news
recently for someone
coming out and saying
that we're all living
in a bubble and kind
of the repercussions from that.
So I that's the hard part.
It's like the us-versus-them
has been solidified,
wherever the blame goes.
And it's sort of like how do
you break out of that mentality.
JAN RIVKIN: So
here's my question.
I like to imagine
a world in which
the creativity of
companies like Google
and the innovativeness,
a portion
got focused on these issues.
I know to some degree
they already are.
Right But if you really like
you turned the battleship
and aimed it straight
at this kind of problem,
imagine what kind of
technological innovations
you'd have that would
make a difference.
I'll just mention one very small
one, which a student at HBS
did almost overnight
right after the election.
And I don't know
if any of you saw
"Hello from the Other Side."
So it was a website
that, basically,
if you were on one side of
the election or the other,
would pair you up with
someone from the other side.
So you could have a civil
conversation, all right,
kind of break down the bubble.
And it's not high-tech.
Right?
It's not a huge thing.
I'm just wondering what
kind of innovations
are out there that we've
not even thought about.
Because I do think--
and this is a broader point
and a speculative point.
You know, part of
the underlying issue
is the mechanisms for collective
action in our society.
And to some degree,
the mechanisms
for collective action have
been undermined in recent years
by various forces.
So imagine, for instance, global
mobility, global mobility--
when you were in a little
town, you actually really
had incentives.
And you were not going to--
you were never going to live
outside that little town.
Your incentives to work
with your neighbors
and make sure the
school systems were good
and the parts were good
and the art museum was good
were enormous.
Right?
Global mobility comes
in, and collective action
become harder.
On the other hand, I see
in technological change
incredible examples
of collective action
that would be mind boggling.
If I had told you
two decades ago
that every day you
and I would rely
upon a crowdsourced
encyclopedia--
right?
First of all, you wouldn't
know what crowdsourced meant.
Right?
But when someone
explained it, you
would have said that's crazy.
And you'd be right.
And yet there's Wikipedia.
So there are these
emerging mechanisms
for collective action.
The question is
can we harness them
toward building the
commons that we need faster
than the old mechanisms decay.
So I don't know if it
makes sense to you.
But I think there is a
positive outcome here
and a positive outlook.
So I saw some other questions.
Let me field them, if I may.
AUDIENCE: How does
automation play into this?
You mentioned it earlier.
But with respect to middle
class and specifically the jobs
that will be there
for the middle class,
what role does automation play?
And it's probably changing
year over year over year
pretty rapidly.
JAN RIVKIN: So that
question has kept
a generation of economists
happy or as close
as they can attain that state.
So you know, I think
actually the best
answer I see to that is actually
talk by David Autor of MIT,
which you can Google
it, and you can find it.
I think it's called "Why Are
There Still So Many Jobs?"
Right?
Because we've gone
through many phases
where people say the
machines are taking our jobs.
Right?
When we went from agriculture
to mass manufacturing,
we were sure there weren't
going to be enough jobs.
Right?
And what happened?
It turns out that
we human beings
can consume more
things insatiably.
Right?
And there's always either
things or services,
and so there are jobs.
And so I think the
answer to the question
will there be jobs
in the future.
Yes, absolutely.
Will you have a job?
For the folks in this room, yes.
More broadly, yes,
you'll have a job.
But I think the question
is what job will it be.
Will be a good job?
And for sure, it will
be a different job.
And that brings with it, I
think, a deeply challenging
time period where there will
be shifts in jobs and shifts
in the skills needed
by individuals.
And you know, I think
the folks in this room,
by and large, are on the
positive side of that, right,
both because you've
got the skills that
are needed in the future
and because you've
got the ability to attain
skills you don't have today.
Unfortunately, our
education system
has not equipped a lot
of people in the country,
or it has failed to equip many
people in the country for that.
And so the question becomes
how do we change that system.
And this is where, I think,
technologically inclined
individuals and their companies
can make a massive difference.
Right now, the race
I see is sobering.
The first thing
you should know is,
when you see people point
to globalization automation,
they should say
globalization in a whisper
and automation in a loud voice.
As far as I can
tell from the data,
the job losses that
you see are about 86%
automation, about
14% globalization.
You'd never know
that from listening
to the political discourse.
All right, it's all about
globalization and outshoring.
And I think the
reason, honestly,
is it's much easier
to say the problem is
someone in China has your job.
Someone preferably,
someone who doesn't
look like you has your job.
And I'm going to fix that.
Right?
And not to say it's
automation, and your skills
aren't advancing fast enough.
So that's the first thing--
so automation, huge thing.
And then in turn, what I find
the most sobering about this--
and I've talked to a number
of venture capitalists
about this-- you talk
to VCs, and they'll
work through their portfolio.
And a lot of the
portfolio involves things
they know will displace jobs.
They'll also create jobs.
But they'll displace jobs.
And then, occasionally,
an enlightened one
will say I'm also looking for
an investment in retraining
because I know
there's going to be
some huge need for retraining.
And yet, I can't find
the organizations
that are doing retraining in
an innovative, massive way.
And so I think the main
social challenge we've got
is how do we make
the transition.
And particularly, can we
bring some of the tools
that technology
brings to enable that?
And I haven't seen anyone
with a great answer to that.
What worries me the most is I
see the private sector creating
the automation.
And I see the retraining
largely in the public sector.
And I kind of know how
that race is likely to end.
Right?
And it's deeply,
deeply worrying.
Other thoughts or questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So one
of the arguments
I've heard from
people who tend to be
on the extreme conservative or
liberal side of the spectrum,
when confronted with
this type of data,
is that yes, but people
in the lower income
percentile actually don't
have it as bad as they did
during the Great Depression.
So it's not really so
bad because of technology
and that that will continue
to make people's lives better
across the board.
And I just wanted to get
your perspective on it.
JAN RIVKIN: Yeah, no.
I think it's a great question.
I think there's some
real truth in it.
And there's also evidence
that points against it.
The real truth in it is we
have a hard time putting
into economic terms adjustments
for how better off am I
because I've got access
to my smartphone.
Right?
And the economic technology
for accounting for that
is not very good.
The other evidence
I see, though,
is if things are so good at that
end of the income distribution,
why are people so mad.
Right?
I don't see--
I don't have a great
answer for that question.
Right?
So for sure, we should
get better at measuring.
But I think we also have
to look in the eye--
the monster that's out there.
And so, you know,
there's another, I think,
deeply interesting question.
Some of my colleagues
work on it.
I don't.
And that is what are the
determinants of happiness.
Right Is it actually
absolute or relative wealth?
And if it's relative
wealth, then, yes, I'm
better off in absolute
terms than people
during the Great Depression.
But I'm actually no happier.
So you know, I think it's a deep
question, not one to which I
have a great answer.
Other thoughts or questions?
Eva.
EVA: Coming from Germany,
I was living in Germany l
those days, are there
any lessons learned
from different countries, from
different economies that we
[INAUDIBLE] here in the US?
JAN RIVKIN: Yeah, no, I
think there are great lessons
in both directions.
The first thing I'd
say is our focus here--
and I worried about
it for an audience
as international as Google.
Right?
The focus here is on the US.
You know, at HBS, we
teach by the case method.
I view the US as, essentially,
the world's largest case study.
Right?
And I think many
of the issues we
see here, in different variants,
apply to advanced economies
around the world.
I think there are indicators
that the same kinds of problems
are arising around the world--
Brexit, actually, the in
Germany just recently.
Right?
I mean I think we can
see that showing up
in the rise of the far right.
Are there lessons from
the rest of the world
that the US can learn?
Absolutely, and I think probably
the apprenticeship system
and the educational
system in northern Europe
may be the best example.
The US, for very good reasons,
very well-intended reasons,
got on a kick toward college
for all, right, and, somehow
or the other, got the impression
out there among individuals
that a college degree,
a bachelor's degree,
no matter what it was in,
right, was the path to success.
And other kinds of
blue collar jobs
just they weren't
knowledge work.
They weren't worthy.
Right?
You couldn't
convince your parents
this is where you should go.
I think that's proven just
to be absolutely wrong.
And in fact, manufacturing
is knowledge work these days.
And there are great jobs
out there that are unfilled.
All right?
And I think Europe has been
much better, much, much better,
at making sure the
idea of the education
was to get people toward
fulfilling and prosperous
lives, not necessarily
toward a college degree.
That said, I understand
deeply, I hope,
why people are so
focused on this.
I was speaking with an
African-American colleague
about this.
And I asked him, why this
college for all thing?
And he said, basically, look.
When you say something not
college for all, what you hear
is not college for all.
What I hear is
college for people
who look a certain way and
not college for other people.
So how we create multiple
paths to prosperity,
as some colleagues at the
Ed School have put it,
while also creating opportunity
that's fairly broadly spread,
I think it's something that's
a uniquely American challenge.
And we've got to take things
like the apprenticeship system
from Europe and figure out
how we do it in a way that's
tailored to this country.
I'll just end with
one last word.
I genuinely think--
I genuinely think we are at
a crossroads in the country.
But the good news is there
actually are two paths.
We're actually at a crossroads.
Right?
There's one path, which is
a kind of path toward unity,
where, for instance,
business leaders understand
the enlightened
self-interest they have,
that they invest in the commons.
They work with the
local government.
And we actually build
the commons back up.
There's another
path, unfortunately,
which is the path
toward division,
and so a path where politicians
realize that, given the media
we've got, dividing
us against one
another is the path
towards success.
And business interests pursue
their narrow self-interest.
And we don't address the
issues in the financial sector
other sectors of our economy.
And we let the
commons deteriorate.
But I think they're are
generally two paths.
And the cool part about it
is we actually get to decide.
There are forces
of globalization
or technological change, which
make one path a little rockier
than the other.
But individually
and collectively,
we can choose the path.
And I hope we all
choose the right one.
Thank you very much for your
thoughts and your questions
and for your time today.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]